do you have any memories of dad yeah  all that i have to describe him as is  basically what he did  avalanche killing the best of our time  alex lowe his body was never recovered  it's like an astronaut lost in space  i can remember conrad arriving on my  doorstep  what could i do for alex what could i do  to take care of all of you  conrad got a phone call he told me  it has to be him it was like he came  back to life  never think you're gonna have to  confront the body of your hero  you can lose someone and still love  someone else  okay like this film it's gonna bring  things out in the open  and then we'll just see if we can  recover from that  you